[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم وفي
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث وتتفاعل
اخرى البدايه من الدار البيضاء واستمرار
الاحتفالات الشعبيه بفوز المغرب على
البرتغال وتاهله لدوري نصف نهائي لمونديال
قطر 2022 في سابقه تاريخيه عربيه ودوليا
رفيعا للجزيره يقول فيه الى حديث الولايات
المتحده عن ارسال ايران مئات الطائرات
المسيره لروسيا مجردتها
والى ليما عاصمه بيروت وغضب شعبي مع
مطالبه انصار الرئيس السابق بيدرو كاسيو
بالافراج عنه واجراء انتخابات مبكرا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
وستتصاعد الاتهامات الغربيه لايران بامداد
روسيا بطائرات مسيره تستخدم في حرب
اوكرانيا طهران تنفي ومسؤول ايرانيه يقول
للجزيره ان واشنطن ونيته تريدان تقديم
بلاده كطرف في الحرب وموسكو تشدد مجددا
على عدم تلقي امدادات العسكريه من ايران
قبل ايام من اجتماع حاسما لوزراء الطاقه
الاوروبيين مفاوضات عاجله بشان سقف اسعار
الغاز خلاف وانقسام يتسع بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وسط مخاوف من تداعيات ارتفاع
تكاليف الوقود ونمو التضخم
قبل اسبوع من انتخابات البرلمانيه هدفها
ارساء نظام رئاسيا معزز قوى سياسيه تدعو
التونسيين الى المقاطعه مظاهره تهدد
بالرئيس وشعارات تطالب برحيله على خلفيه
الازمه الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه اناقشنا المشهد المازوم في تونس
سياسيا واقتصاديا قبل اسبوعين من
الانتخابات النيابيه من شانها ان تؤدي الى
برلمان محدود سلطات وتعزيز صلاحياته منصب
الرئيس باستطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم الى اي مدى يؤثر المشهد المتوتر في
تونس على المشاركه في الانتخابات نحو
ثلاثه وخمسين في المئه قالوا ان التاثير
كبير في حين رجح 22% ان يكون التاثير
محدودا بينما اختار 25% القول انه لا
تاثير اطلاقا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمزي كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على منصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشر دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
تتابعون جوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات
المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل
مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
يحتضم السجال بين طهران وعواصم غربيه بعد
اعلان كياف رصدها استخدام المسيارات في
قصف منشات الطاقه بالبلاد من جهه ثانيه
تتحدث مصادر امريكيه عن صفقه تحصل بموجبها
ايران على مقاتلات سوخوي المتطوره اما
ايران فهي على موقفها نفي متجدد واتهام
للغرب بمحاولته شيطانها
في دائره الاتهام في اي صله من مسيرات
ايران بالحرب في اوكرانيا
يصير خلفاء الغربيون على ربط المساله اين
في الاونه الاخيره تكثفت اتهاماتهم لطهران
بتزويد موسكو بمئات الطائرات المسيره التي
تستخدم في تلك الحرب
ذاك اذا صح ما تخشى واشنطن من ارتقائه الى
شركه دفاعيه كامله بين الجانبين
عن مصادر امريكي ان ايران ستتسلم طائرات
المقاتله من الدرجه الاولى من روسيا خلال
العام المقبل مقابل طائرات كاميكازي بدون
طيار التي تستخدمها في ساحه المعركه في
اوكرانيا
صدى المخاوف الامريكيه بشانه
حتى اين تحديث الاستخباراتيا من وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه يذهب الى ان ايران
اصبحت واحده من اكبر الداعمين العسكريين
لروسيا منذ بدء حربها في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ترد طهران يوضح مسؤول الايراني رفيع
للجزيره ان الاتهامات الغربيه لبلاده
بتزويد موسكو سيارات عاريه عن الصحه
علاقات ايران الدفاعيه مع روسيا وتصويرها
طرفا في الحرب وذلك لتحقيق مكاسبه سياسيه
كما يشير المسؤول الايراني تطوير بلاده
الشراكه الدفاعيه والعسكريه مع روسيا ليس
امرا جديدا وليس مواجا ضد اي دوله
ما زالت ايران تؤكد انها ليست طرفا في
الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا تدعم استمرارها وما
زال الاوكرانيون في المقابل يعددون ما
يقولون انها هجمات روسيه بمسيرات ايرانيه
الصنع على نظام الطاقه والبنيه التحديث
الحساسه في مختلف الحاء البلاد
في العواصم الغربيه ينبهون الى ان الدعم
الايراني للجيش الروسي سينمو في الشهور
القادمه
في ايران اما الامريكيون فينظرون في خيار
جمع دول عده لمناقشه عرقله ما بدت لهم
شراكه روسيه ايرانيه مقلقه
على مدار اشهر الحرب في اوكرانيا واجهت
ايران اتهامات غربيه بتزويد روسيا بطائرات
مسيره لاستخدامها في الحرب وشدد الظهران
في كل مره على ان تعاونها الدفاعين مع
روسيا لا يتعلقوا بحرب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لنظيره الاوكرانيين اتهامات امريكيه بشان
تزويد روسيا بالمسيرات الايرانيه
لاستخدامها في حرب اوكرانيا لا اساس لها
من الصحه اعلنت اوكرانيا لاحقا في شهر
سبتمبر افضل مستوى العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
مع ايران بسبب ما وصفته بالقرار العادئي
الايراني بتزويد روسيا بطائره مسيره اقر
وزير الخارجيه الايراني في منتصف الشهر
التالي في حديث مع مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي ان ايران تتعاون دفاعيا
مع روسيا لكنها تتبنى كما قال سياسه عدم
ارسال السلاح الى اي من طرفين نزاع وفي
الثالثه والعشرين من اكتوبر علقت الخارجيه
الايرانيه على عقوبات فرضها الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبريطاني على طيران على خلفيه
مزاعم التزويد روسيا بالمسيرات ووصفتها
بالاجراء المخرب وغير المسؤول ثم اعلن
وزير الخارجيه الايراني في نهايه الشهر
اكتوبر بلاده لعقد اجتماع على مستوى خبراء
عسكريين مع اوكرانيا من دون وصفات لبحث
الاتهامات الموجهه لطهران اقر في وقت لاحق
ان ايران قدمت لروسيا عددا محدودا من
المسيرات قبل الحرب واكد ان ذلك لم يكن من
اجل استخدامها في اوكرانيا ثم عاد حسين
امير عبد اللاهان ليؤكد لاحقا ان ايران
واوكرانيا عقد تاشي معا على مستوى خبراء
السياسيين وعسكريين ولم تقدم كياب اي دليل
يثبت استخدام تلك المسيارات في الحرب على
اوكرانيا وفي الثانيه عشر من ديسمبر قالت
الخارجيه الايرانيه لدى استدعائها السفير
البريطانيه في طهران ان الاتهامات الموجهه
اليها بشان مسيرات عاريه عن الصحه ولا
اساس لها وتفتقر للادله
[موسيقى]
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من لندن
توبايس الود رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس
العموم البريطاني ومعنى من طهران علي اكبر
داريني الباحث والمتخصص في الدراسات
الايرانيه الامريكيه مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك
علي اكبر دارين طهران تنفي هذه الاتهامات
ولكن براي المسؤولين الايرانيين ما ما
ماذا وراءها ماذا خلفها
ولكنها تدعم روسيا في هذه الحرب من الواضح
ان ايران قدمت اسلحه وسيارات لروسيا قبل
بدايه هذه الحرب لا اعرف ماذا كانت ايران
تستمر بتزويد روسيا بالاسلحه حتى الان
ايران لم تؤكد ذلك ولكن ما من شيء
ابدا بهذا الموضوع ايران لديها كل الحق
بان تبيع الاسلحه الى روسيا او ان تشتري
الاسلحه من روسيا هذه العقوبات رافعات
وايران يحق لها ان تبيع الاسلحه الدول
الغربيه تبيع كميات كبيره من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا وترسل واسلحه الى اوكرانيا وهذا
جيد بالنسبه اليها لذلك لماذا تقول هذه
الدول انه من الخطا ان تقوم ان تقوم ايران
لان روسيا هي هنا الطرف الذي يقوم بشان
الحرب على بلد سيد بينما اوكرانيا هي في
موقع المدافع عن النفس
في هذه الحرب
السيئه وفي هذه اللعبه السيئه نحن نتحدث
عن حرب بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وروسيا وليس بين اوكرانيا وروسيا ان
الولايات المتحده تستهدف خصومها واعدائها
من خلال
الاستخدام الاستراتيجي لهذه الامور
وتستخدم العمق الاستراتيجي ذهبت الى
اوكرانيا لاحتواء روسيا والى تايوان ده
احتواء الصين ومنطقه الخليج لاحتواء ايران
هذا نمط الايراني
نصل الى هذه النتيجه في ظل كل الضغوط التي
وضعت على كل من روسيا وايران
السخيفه التي استمعنا اليها انا ادعوا
الضيف الاخر كي يزور اوكرانيا وسوف يرى
بام العين بشكل واضح ان روسيا هاجمت
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا تتعرض للهجوم والجيد هو
ان روسيا تفشل في اوكرانيا ولذلك تعتمد
الان على ايران لمنظومه الاسلحه الجديده
كي تعزز موقفها في اوكرانيا ولكن دعونا لا
نستخدم اي تمريرات مرتبطه بالمشاكل
الدوليه بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للتغطيه على حقيقه ان روسيا
اجتاحت دوله اخرى وايران يجب ان لا ترسل
اسلحه تساعد روسيا في قتل المزيد من
المدنيات في اوكرانيا
كانت هناك ضغوط الشديده على روسيا وايضا
على ايران الم تكن هذه الدول الغربيه
تتوقع ان تصل الامور الى هذه النتيجه في
ضوء كل الضغوط التي وضعتها على الدولتين
نعم افترض انه عندما تنفذ الذخائر
وتبدا همم روسيا بالبحث عن الاطراف التي
يمكن ان تساعدها روسيا ليس لديها اصدقاء
متعددين على انجح الصين وبكل تاكيد ايراد
وايران لديها مشاكل متعدده في الداخل في
الحقيقه
اسف ان ارى ان ايران تساعد روسيا في غزلها
لدوله اخرى ايران يمكنها ان تقوم بالامر
في هذه المرحله يجب ان لا تساعد روسيا
لدى ايران حاليا في ان تصبح جزءا من هذه
الازمه العالميه الدائره بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بمعزل عن الشراكه التاريخيه في
همم الدفاعيه بين همم البلدين
الامر بسيط للغايه نحن نتحدث عن علاقات
دوليه دراسه حاله في هذا المجال ان الحرب
حصلت في اوكرانيا بغض النظر عن موقف ايران
ما الذي يتعين على ايران ان تقوم به يتعين
على ايران ان تحميه مصالحها الوطنيه اذا
ما كسبت الولايات المتحده في هذه الحرب
سوف نعود الى رؤيه تمدد وتوسع دور
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والنظام الاحادي القطب في العالم وهذا
يؤذي ايران ودول اخرى ولكن اذا ما انتصرت
روسيا سوف نرى النظام عالميا متعدد
الاقصاب واا يظهر بشكل اوضح هو اسرع
وايران تفضل نظاما متعدد الاقطاب على ان
يكون مهيمن عليه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ما كسبت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا سوف تعود الى نفس
النمط الذي رايناه في غرب اسيا وهذه كارثه
بالنسبه الى ايران واا منطقه الشرق الاوسط
برومتها
الغربيه بان هذا التحالف والتقارب بين
ايران وروسيا سيتم وضع حد له كيف يترجم
هذا الامر
اننا لا نتحدث عن الولايات المتحده فقط بل
عن الاسره الدوليه التي تدعم الديمقراطيات
في كل انحاء العالم هي تدعم اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا الدوله تعرضت لغزوه من قبل
الدوله اخرى لم نرى هذا الامر لسنوات طوال
واعتقد ان المفارقه هنا غريبه بان الضيف
تحدث عن اجنده الولايات المتحده وفي الوقت
نفسه ايران تستخدمه النفوذ في اليمن في
لبنان في العراق في سوريا وحتى في البحرين
من اجل زعزعته السلام والاستقرار والتاثير
في هذه البلدان لتغيير مجريات الاحداث
الداخليه
الدول الغربيه بريطانيا مثلا حدثنا عن
بريطانيا كي يتم وضع حد بهذا اعتقاره
اذا
اثبت بان ايران ترسل منظومات اسلحه لروسيا
اتوقع المزيد من العقوبات تفرض على ايران
وهذا ما لا تريده ايران سوف نرى ضغوطا
اضافيه من قبل الشعب الايراني ضد النظام
الايراني
من لندن وشكرا لدكتور علي اكبر دوريلي
الباحث المتخصص في الدراسات الايرانيه
الامريكيه ضيفنا من طهران
مع ارتفاع الاصوات الغربيه
من المسيرات خصوصا خلال حربها في اوكرانيا
تخطف الانظار بعض اصناف هذه الطائرات
الايرانيه من دون طيار حيث استطاعت ان
تحدث فرقا على الارض ما عدم كلفتها مقارنه
باسلحه وصواريخ غربيه اخرى تتعرفوا على
اهمها في هذا العرض
في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي اعلنت اوكرانيا
انها تمكنت للمره الاولى من اسقاط طائره
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراز الشاهد 136
في منطقه
وتستخدمها القوه الروسيه
اعتذارك بضعه اسابيع بعد ان كشف مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جاكسون عزما روسيا
شراء مئات من الطائره القتاليه الايرانيه
بدون طيار لاستخدامها في اوكرانيا نفس
طهران رسميا ان يكون لديها نيه لبيع طائره
مسيره لروسيا وانما سلمته منها كان قبل
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
بهذه المسيرات ياتي لتميزها بقدرات تحليق
طويله وتنوع اغراضها بين المراقبه
والاستطلاع العسكري والهجوم بالذخائر
الناريه او بالاستضدام بالهدف والانفجار
من ابرازها المسيرته الصغيره تشاهد 100
وست 136
ونحو 200 كيلو غرام وتعتبر رخيصه لتربح
قيمتها بين 520000 دولار مقارنه كمثال
بكلفه صواريخ كاليبر او توماهوك
تطلقوه على شكل اسراب ولانها بطيئه ولا
تستطيع التحليق على ارتفاعات عاليه يتم
اعتراض عدد كبير منها لكن نفذ مسيره او
اثنتين بنحوي 40 كلغراما كافر لاحداث ذمار
كبير المسيره الاخرى التي اعتقدوا ان
ايران بعثها لروسيا هي مهاجر سته التي
تستخدم في مهام المراقبه والاستطلاع
والتصوير والهجوم وبدات ايران انتاجها عام
الغرام وقدره على البقاء في الجو الاتنه
عشر ساعه ويبلغ مداها اكثر من 2000 كلم
وهذه المسيره مجاهزه بكاميرا حراريه
وبصريه وتحمل اربعه قنابل ذكيه دقيقه
وتشبه من حيث الوظيفه والحجم مسيره باقدار
اثنين التركيبيه وما قد يعكس اهتمام طهران
بهذه الصناعه افتتاح رئيس كان الجيش
الايراني محمد باقيلي مصنعا لانتاج طائره
استطلاع مسيره من طراز ابابيل 2 في
العاصمه التاجيكيه ديسمبر فيما يويار
الماضي
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس
الاوكرانيسا صعب جدا بعد قصف روسيا قال
انه ترك اكثر من مليون ونصف المليون مواطن
بلا كهرباء وكان مراسل الجزيره قد نقل عن
مسؤولين اوكرانيين انا عند ذات الكهرباء
والماء انقطعت عن مناطق في نيكولايب
وخرسون واديسا بعد قصف روسيا او دا بحياته
شخصين وفق ما اكدته سلطاته خرسان المواليه
لاوكرانيا من جهه افاد الجيش الاوكراني
باستمرار القصف الروسيه على مقاطعاته
خيرسون وميكو لايف وزابولوجيا وديني برو
جنوبيه البلاد وعلى خارج كيف ومدن ومدن
وبلدان في الشرق
ضربات المركزه تواصل روسيا استهداف العصب
الاوكرانيه الحساس على امتداد خريطتها في
وقت يبدو الاصعب اي البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
في فصل الشتاء
السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت ان مسيرات
انتحاريه ضربت البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوديسا وان الاف الاشخاص بلا كهرباء
ولاميه ومثل هذا الحال من انقطاع لامدادات
المياه والكهرباء المناطق في نيكولايف
وخيرسون احدثه قصف روسي وفقا لمسؤولين
اوكرانيين
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وصفه الهجمه الروسيه
المستمره منذ اكتوبر الماضي على النظام
الطاقه بغير مسبوقه في العالم وقالت ان
الضربات الروسيه المتعمده تستهدف بدقه
مولدات الكهرباء وشبكه نقلهم انطلاقا من
معرفه الروسي بمنظومه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
كما تحدث مسؤولون اوكرانيون قبل ايام عن
ان اكثر من 500
كهرباء بفعل ضربات القوات الروسيه وبنفس
الاتهام تواجه القوات الاوكرانيه السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في اقليم دوم بس قالت ان
الاوكرانيين يتعمدون استهداف البنيه
التحتيه واخرها قصف بصواريخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه استهدف منشات للبنيه التحتيه في
مقاطعه لوجانز لا يخفي المسؤولون الروسي
للاستهداف المتعمد من قواتهم لمنشات
الطاقه في اوكرانيا وهو من وجهه نظرهم رد
مناسب معتبرين ان الاوكرانيين هم من بداوا
ضرب المنشات الروسيه المدنيه وابرزها
تفجير جسر القرم في اكتوبر الماضي ومن نتج
عنه من ضرر جزئي رغم ان كياب لم تعلن
صراحه مسؤوليتها عن تفجير الجسر الحيوي
تعتبر مدينه سنيريكا جنوب اوكرانيا اخر
مدن مقاطعه نيكولايف التي ساعدتها القوات
الاوكرانيه من القوات الروسيه وقد كانت
القوه الروسيه تستخدمها كقاعده لاستهداف
عمق مدينه ميكولايف مراسلنا تامر الصمادي
دخل مدينه سنيريكا للمره الاولى منذ
سعادتها ورصد لنا الاوضاع بداخلها
معاقل الروس في مقاطعه ميكولاي ساره
اوكرانيا خالصا
او ما تبقى منها تتحرر من قبضه روسيا
لطالما شكلت هذه المدينه حلقه وصل مهمه
بين مناطق شرق ميكولاج وشمال خرسون هدوء
مخيف تعيشه سنيريكا اليوم تخريقه اصوات
النيران التي تسمع من فينه لاخرى يقول
لاكرانيون ان هذه المدينه باتت تجسد خساره
استراتيجيه لروسيا
[موسيقى]
اثار المعارك العنيفه لا تخطئها العين
بقايا عتاد ومركبات الروسيه تكشف ضراوه
المواجهات
انظروا الى ما خلفه الروس في مدينتنا هذا
هو السلام الروسي اثناء وجودهم كنا نعيش
في اقليه المدارس حياتنا كانت صعبه
خلفت الحرب تبعات ثقيله اكثر من 13000
كانوا يسكنون المدينه قبل الحرب لم يبقى
منهم سوى المئه في زمن الحرب يحرص
الاوكرانيون على ابرازي تكاتفهم
نوبه ايش الدخول الروس الى ريفكا وخروجهم
منها ضي
قتنا نحن الان نتنفس الحريه
في الطرقات كانوا يعاملوننا بقسوه
كثير من الطرقات المحيطه بمنزل فيكتوريا
تحولت الى طرق للموت بسبب الالغام الروسيه
كادما انه شري عندما بدا الجنود الروس
المغادره كانت البيوت تهتز على وقع
الياتهم قبل ذلك زرع الغاما في الجوار
ووضعوا قذائف في المنازل
حتى بدا الجيش الاوكراني عمليه تفكيك
الالغم يقول انه فكك منذ بدايه الحرب اكثر
من ثمانين الف عبوه ناسفه في عموم البلاد
تتواصلوا مفاوضات دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في
محاوله لوضع اتفاق للحد من اسعار الغازي
خلال اجتماع لوزراء الطاقه المقرر في
الثالث عشر من هذا الشهر ولا تزال الدول
منقسمه اذا ذالك ويسود الشك في امكانيه
التوصل الى اتفاق يرضي مختلف الاطراف
قبيله الاجتماع المرتقب
يزداد الانقسام الاوروبي
تتباين الاراء حول الامر منذ بدايه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا ويفرد الامر نفسه الان
بشده مع حلول فصل الشتاء بدا سياله واضحه
حاليا من خلال مفاوضات الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الراميه لوضع اتفاق لاسعار الغاز
خلال الاجتماع لوزاره الطاقه يوم الثلاثاء
القادم
اثنتا عشره دوله بين هذا بلجيكا وايطاليا
وبولندا تسعى خفض كبير لصق في الاتحاد
المزمار لاسعار الغاز وتطالب مقترحاتها
بان يكون الحد الاقصى للسعر اقل كثيرا عن
احدث مستوى تتفاوض الدول بشانه من الناحيه
الثانيه فان صوت الدول المعارضه لهذا
الاقتراح وبينها المانيا
وتطرح هذه الدول مقترحات اخرى بينها ضروره
ان يضمن ان تدخل استمرار الاسعار في اطار
تنافسي مع بقيه دول العالم
لكني يبدو ان كل هذه الاقتراحات قابله
للتغيير قبل او اثناء اجتماعي وزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيين يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
وكان الاجتماع السابق للوزراء اواخر
نوفمبر الماضي قد فشل في الاتفاق على وضع
حد اقصى لاسعار الغاز الروسيه في هذه
الاثناء يحذر البنك المركزي الاوروبي من
انهيار الاستقرار المالي والانعكاسات
السالبه التي قد تترتب على تحديد السقف
لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي على مستوى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولا يخفي قلقه من شان المخاطر
المحتمله على مدمن الاسواق الماليه
الاوروبيه روسيه تراقب الموقف بحذر وتعتقد
موسكو ان اي تحديدا لاسعار الغاز سيكبد
اوروبا خسائر كبيره ويقول نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي
على اتخاذ التدابير اللازمه للحد من
العواقب مشددا على ان على الغرب الاستعداد
للرد الروسي في حال الاقتراب من اسعار
غازيها الطبيعيه عموما يعتقد كثيرون ان
اوروبا وان تمكنت من ربح حرب الغاز
الحاليه واتازت الشتاء الراهن بسلام فان
الازمه تظل هاجسا كبيرا تعيشه دول الاتحاد
ولو بمستويات مختلفه ويتعين عليها البحث
عن سبل ضمان استمرار امدادات الغاز
مستقبلا بما يضمن لها تفوقا على المدى
الطويل لا يجزم بامكانيه حدوثه احد
نفى وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف
وجود اي لعبه سياسيه او جيو سياسيه في
مبادره انشاء اتحاد للغاز بين روسيا
وكزاخستان واوزباكستان واكد لافروف في
حديث لقناه كازاخستانيه ان الهدف من هذه
المبادره هو ضمان وعدم وقوع اي انقطاعات
في امدادات الغاز بين الدول الثلاثاء
الجاره في
الوقت
عن لعبه سياسيه او جيو سياسيه ليس هناك اي
لعبه روسيا وكزاخستان واوزباكستان دول
متجاوره وتملك نظاما مشتركا لنقل الغاز
وهي مهتمه بضمان عدم حدوث انقطاعم في
الامدادات مع مراعاه ذروه الاستهلاك
الموسمي
[موسيقى]
نظمت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه المعارضه في
تونس مظاهره دعت فيها تونسيين وبقيه اطراف
المعارضه الى التوحدي لانقاذ ما تصفه
بالديمقراطيه المغدوره ووضع حد للانقلاب
وقال رئيس الجبهه احمد نجيب الشابي ان
الرئيس قيس سعيد بصدد الانفراد بالسلطه
لكنه في مازق وامام ازمه سياسيه خانقه
ومعارضه قويه على حديث ياتي هذا تحرك قبل
اسبوع من الانتخابات التشريعيه التي اقرها
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ضمن خطته خريطه
الطريق
الاول من الانتخابات التشريعيه التي دعت
الجبهه مرارا الى مقاطعتها باعتبارها
مفتقده مقومات النزاهه والشفافيه حسب
الجبهه شانها شان جميع المحطات التي اعقبت
اقرار الرئيس الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في
البلاد
لترفع بذلك شعار رئيسا الا وهو رحيل
الرئيس
جاي يمثل الاعظم اصبح المواطن عنده صعوبه
انت عايش مؤشرات الماليه والاقتصاديه
للدوله متجهه نحولانيار وقيس سعيد لا
يبالي بذلك لم تختصر دائره المعارضين
للرئيس قيس سعيد والدعين الى مقاطعه
الانتخابات التشريعيه على جبهه الخلاص
الوطني فحسب شمل التنسيقيه الاحزاب
الديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه المشكله من خمسه
كيانات سياسيه يسريه والديمقراطيه اضافه
الى حزب افاق تونس والحزب الدستوري الحر
كما وجه الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وهو
اكبر المنظمات العماليه انتقادا للمسار
الانتخابيه معتبرا اياه بلا لون
ورغم اتساع دائره المتحفظين على مسار بات
يصفه الكثيرون بالانفرادي فان اصوات اخرى
تعد هذا المسار ضروري لتشكيل مشهد سياسي
ينهي 10 سنوات يصفونها بالسوداء من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه هناك بعض
الصعوبات التي قد تدفع التونسيين الى
مقاطعات المسار ولكن حتى هو وقعت مقاطعه
هذه المسار قد تكون مقاطع جزئيه وقد يكون
العزوف كبير ولكن هذا المسار سيستمر نظرا
لانه تقريبا لا توجد معارضه فعليه في تونس
وفيما تتجه الانظار الى الانتخابات
التشريعيه القادمه وكيف ستكون نسب
المشاركه والمقاطعه فان الوضع المعيشي اخذ
في التراجع بالنظر الى تدهور القدره
الشرائيه للمواطنين وتراجع اغلب المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه وهو محور الاهتمام الاول
التونسيين والاختبار الحقيقي لاصحاب
السلطه
للانتخابات المقبله تتجه تونس نحو محطه
جديده يراها الرئيس ضروري خلي القطع مع
الماضي وراءه خصومه تكريسا للانقلاب سيف
الدين معالج الجزيره تونس
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس بالحسن
اليحياوي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومختار
الجماعي المحامي والناشط الحقوقي مرحبا
بكما سيد بلحسن اليحياوي اذن المعارضه
تقول الرئيس في مازق امام ازمه سياسيه
خانقه ومعارضه قويه ما رايك
كبير من التونسيين حول الرئيس السيسي طيب
هي هذه المعارضه هذه المعارضه التي تصمها
اذانها الا على خطابها الداخليه او صوتها
الداخلي الذي يكرر منذ الخامس والعشرين 21
في ناس الروايه او في نفس
الحكايه حكايه الانقلاب حكايه التونسيين
يقولون قصص سعيد وحكايات ان هناك سوف
تتدخلون
الى الرحيل وما الى ذلك وهذا طبعا يعطي
فرصه كبيره للرئيس سعيد لكي يمضي كل من في
مشروعيه او في خريطه الطريق التي رسمها
منذ بدايه
يعني لماذا هذا الكلام يعطيه فرصه كبيره
ان كانت هناك معارضه معارضه تعتبر انه
يكرس حكم الفرد
نعم ولكن هذه المعارضه هي السبب الرئيسي
التي تفعل كثير من التونسيين الالتفات حول
الرئيس السيسي
بحل البرلمان واسقاط الحكومه هذه المعارضه
هو السبب الرئيسي الذي دفع التونسيين الى
الوقوف وراء قيس السعيد
يعني المشكله اساسا ان هذه الاحزاب التي
تعارض هذه الاجراءات الان اختبرت واخفقت
في الحكم هكذا يقول مؤيد الرئيس سعيد
لا بدلنا نعتقد ان هذا قولنا نردون
لاننا لا ننكر ان
قيس منا واضح مع المعارضه بالفعل مرت
المسار الثوره التونسيه بعديد من الهزات
ولكنه لم يبلغ من
انسداد الافقي ما بلغه اليوم والدليل على
ذلك ان حتى المعارضه التي كانت تعارض
الحكم النهضه وشركائها وكان تدعك عيسى
تصبوا يوما ضد السعيد قيس سعيد لم يبقى له
الان وما يتحدث عنهم
الكريم من ان المعارضه ثم انها بالعكس
سعيد اليوم هو الذي يظلمه تعمد
ومع السفر الى السعوديه في ظل ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وسياسيه والبلاد داخله
على مسرحيه من الكوميديا السوداء الحزينه
مختلفه
الانتخابات
يقول ان هذا الكلام هو ما دفع بالتونسيين
الى الالتفاف حول ما قام به الرئيس
لانه حتى الاقبال على خيارات الرئيس تاكد
ان الشعب التونسي لم يلتفت اليها وان
المسرحيه انطلت عليه
ثم استوى بعد ذلك في المناسبات الوطنيه
بمناسبه
الاستفتاء وايضا بمناسبه حتى
لهذه الانتخابات المزمعيه اجرؤها كثير من
الدوام لم تجد مجرد المترشحين
فونياء ستجدوا
اليوم اا لم يعد يدقوا بوعود قيس سعيده
خاصه وانه يزيد الاسعار نهارا ليلتقي رئيس
الحكومه
وي
وصيده
ومراعاه القدره الشرائيه للمواطلي اذا
نعتقد ان الحسن الدوله التونسيه تسير نحو
حقوق لا حول لا اله الا عز الرئيس وخروجه
وذلك
باسم الحسن اليحياوي
اذا همم يقول ضيفنا ان الرئيس هو من يصوم
اذانه لحديث
وشكوى هذه الاحزاب من ان ما يحصل هو تكريس
لحكم الفرد وان هذا الالتفاف الشعبي الذي
تتحدث عن لم يتجلى لم نراه يتجلى مثلا في
استفتاء الدستور والان هناك دعوات مشابهه
للمقاطعه
نعم استنى مساله اساسيه يجب الانتباه
عليها تونسيون اكثرهم يدركون تماما حتى
انهزم يكون الرئيس السيسي
ويدركون ان المشكله الحقيقي هو تلك
الاحزاب البرلمانيه التي كانت تتقاسمها
غنيمه السلطه في ما بينها ولا تقدم
للتونسيين الى الكذب والوعود الجوفاء
واغلب تونسيين يعني ما المعيار في النطق
والحديث باكثريه التونسيين
نعم معلمات هو الانتخابات قبل الاستفتاء
كانت تتم شريهان كبيره على ان التونسيين
لم يذهبوا المشاركه الى الاستفتاء وفي
نهايه الامر وجدنا تقريبا ان النفس الكتله
الانتخابيه النشطه التي تشارك في كل
المحطات الانتخابيه من سنه الانتخابات 14
و19 تقريبا
نعم انا اتحدث عددين الان لا اتحدث عن
نساء حوالي ثلاثه ملايين ناخذ كانت دائما
هي الكتله الانتخابيه النشطه المزاج
الانتخابي في تونس يجنحو بمعظمه الى
العزوف عن المشاركه في الانتخابات و دائما
ما كانت تقريبا نسبه العزوف على
الانتخابات في حدود 60 بالمئه دائما كنا
امام ثلاثه ملايين صوت
انتخابيط هو تقريبا نفس الكتله في وجهنا
في الاستفتاء وقد يفاجئ بعض الاحزاب وبعض
الاتراك في ان هذه الانتخابات التشريعيه
المقبله سوف تشهد اقبالا اكثر
الجماعي ان كانت الاحزاب المعارضه التي
تظهرت اليوم في تونس تدعو الى المقاطعه
يبدو ان مصير المقاطعه
وتدني اي نسبه في التصويت سيلقى نفس مصير
ما حدث مع
استفتاء على الدستور ماذا ستفعل كيف
ستتصرف المعار اذا ذلك
م ما تغطيه
الحب لا اقبل من الشعب ولا من المترشحين
ولا حماسه في خوف انتخابات مثل مشاهدناها
في 2013
ايضا الكتله الانتخابيه ايه ترى قيس سعيد
لا نستغربوه ان يتجهه صوب التزوير خاصه
وان الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات فقدت اهم
شروقها
الاستقلالليه يتحول الى التعيين من طرف
السياسيه لذا فان
انا فان
ان يجب ان ينظر ويجب ان يضعف قيس سعيد
ليتاكد من عزوبي الشعب التونسي
ما يدعو اليه والازمه التي يعيشها وذلك
اؤكد واقول بانه لابد من الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر في المعارضه السوريه المسلحه
للجزيره بان الجيش التركي المتمركز في
مناطقها الحدوديه الشماليه سوريا استهدف
مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في محيط عفرين بريف حلب وقالت مصادر محليه
ان طائرات مسيرات تركيه حلقت في سماء
مدينه عين العرب شرقيه حلب كما تعرضت
مواقع عندما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في قريه تل اللبن بمحيط عين عيسى في ريف
الحسكه لقصف من المدفعيه التركيه التي
استهدفت ايضا المواقع للقوات نفسها في
محيط تل ابيض بريفي الرقه
وافادت وزاره الدفاع التركيه في تغريده
على تويتر بمقتل من وصفته باحد ارهابيين
حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
وقالت انه كان يتولى قياده ما تسمى قوات
تحرير عفرين في منطقه غصن الزيتون
طالبت انقره موسكو بالالتزام بالتفاهمات
التي اورمت بشان الوضع في شمال سوريا وعقب
مشاورات سياسيه عقدت بين تركيا وروسيا في
اسطنبول قالت الخارجيه التركيه ان الوفده
التركيه اكد اصرار انقره على مكافحه حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه التي وصفها بالمنظمه الارهابيه في
سوريا اضافت الوزاره في بيان ان الوفد
التركي اكد ان هذه تنظيمات لا تهدد وحده
اراضي سوريا فقط بل تهدده الامن القوميه
التركيه ايضا
ادت حكومه جديده في بيرو واليمين
الدستوريه امام الرئيسه المؤقته دينا
البرتو التي تولت الحكمه عقب الاطاحه
بالرئيس اليسري بيدروكاستيو بتهمه محاوله
الانقلاب والفساد ويراس الحكومه المكونه
من 17 وزيرا من الاختصاصيين المحامي بيدرو
ميجال ان خلورانا في وقت تسلمت فيه وزاره
الخارجيه ان سيسيليا جرافيسي ياتي ذلك في
وقت تتواصل فيه احتجاجاته مؤيدين رئيس
المعزول وسط العاصمه وفي مختلفه المدن
البيروفيه للمطالبه بالافراج عن كاستيو
واجراء انتخابات الرئاسيه
البيرو الجديده الحكومه الجديده في القصر
الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
عوده الى سجان تجدد في الساعه الاخيره
تتهم كيف وحلفائها الغربيون روسيا
باستخدام مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع لشنها جمال
في اوكرانيا تقول لندن على لسان سفيره
بريطانيا لدى الامم المتحده
ايران نقلت منذ اغسطس اب مئات الطائرات
المسيره الى روسيا البيت الابيض حذر من
تشكل شراكه دفاعيه كامله
مثل الطائرات المسيره والمروحيات
والمقاتلات وقال ان ايران تدرس بيعه مئات
الصواريخ البالستيه لروسيا ردا على ذلك
كشف البنتاجون عن مساعدات لاوكرانيا تشمل
معدات مضاده للطائرات مسيره اضافه الى
ذخيره لانظمه صواريخها هاي مارس الدقيقه
80,000 قذيفه مدفعيه عيار 155 مللي متر
اقرت طهران الشهر الماضي بارسال طائرات
مسيره الى روسيا لكنها شددت على انها
زودتها بها قبل بدء غزوها اوكرانيا
في اجتماع لمجلس الامن الدولي امس الجمعه
بشان مساله توريد الاسلحه لطرفي الحرب في
اوكرانيا لفت روسيا مره اخرى تلقي اسلحه
من طهران دون الاشاره الى الاتهامات
الامريكيه بدعمها لايران تقول بريطانيا
وفرنسا والمانيا والولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا
روسيا بطائرات مسيره ايرانيه ينتهكوا قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي لعام 2015 الذي صدق على
الاتفاق النووي الايراني المشكله والسجال
المتعلق بالمسيرات ليس سياسيا او عسكريا
فقط بل
يتجه الى اتهامات من عواصم غربيه لايران
بنتهاك قرارات الامم المتحده بموجب القرار
كان حظر الاسلحه التقليديه على ايران ساري
المفعول حتى اكتوبر تشرين الاول عام 2020
لكن اوكرانيا والقوى الغربيه تقول ان
القرار لا يزال يتضمن قيودا على الصواريخ
والتقني ذات الصله حتى اكتوبر تشرين الاول
2023 ويمكن ان يشمل تصدير وشراء انظمه
عسكريه متطوره مثل الطائرات المسيره
في تقرير الحديث يقول الامن العام للامم
المتحده ان نقل الطائرات مسيره او
الصواريخ البالستيه التي يزيد مداها عن
300 كم من ايران الى دوله اخرى يتطلب
موافقه مسبقه من مجلس الامن
ويواجهه انطونيو بوتياريش ضغوطا من الغرب
لارسال خبراء الى اوكرانيا لفحص الطائرات
المسيره التي تم اسقاطها في اوكرانيا لكن
روسيا تقول انه لا يملكوا تفويضا لذلك من
بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس
حنا ما الذي يقلق الغرب من ما يسميه هذه
الشراكه الدفاعيه بين ايران وروسيا
اولا اذا ترسخت ال ال التعاملات بين
الفريقين تصبح عشراكه استراتيجيه تصبح
هناك
نقل المعلومات نقل خبرات وتبادل سلاح وهذا
الامر لا سوف لن يكون فقط للاستعمال
والاستغلال على الساحه الاوكرانيه هناك
ابعاد مختلفه هناك ابعاد في الخليج هناك
ابعاد في الهلال الخصيب سوريا العراق هناك
موضوع النووي ماذا سيجري بحقه بلس وان
هناك مساعدات سياسيه والاهم ايضا هناك
التقنيات الحديثه التي قد تعطي لايران
منها السلاح يتم الحديث عن
السخوي»
تقوي موقع ايران ونحن نعرف موقع ايران في
الصراع الاقليمي لقيت المتحده الامريكيه
خاصه واسرائيل طيب همم في موضوع المسيارات
عميد الياس يجري الحديث عن تطوير هذه
المسيارات بين روسيا وايران من جهه وايضا
الان لدينا اتهامات روسيه بان اخرى ايضا
تدخل المسيارات وبدات باستهداف اراضي في
داخل روسيا بها ما هو المشهد المقبل في
هذا الاطار
المشهد المقبل المسيره ال سي هي ارخص اقل
كلفه من كل الاسلحه ليس لها ثمان سياسي
بسيطه على سبيل المثال الشاهد همم 136
يعني ثمن قليل جدا 20,000 دولار يقال
بينما المسيرات الاخرى الغربيه كبيره كلفه
اليوم ما جرى من مسيرات اوكرانيه الى
الداخل والعمق الروسي تقول روسيه ان هذه
المسير ايضا هي من صنع ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي تم تعديلها لاستعمالها ليوم نحن
في مرحله جديده من استعمال سلاح جديد ليس
لدينا رد حتى الان وليس له هناك تكتكات
اساسيه وهي اقل كلفه من كل الاسلحه ولكنها
يعني تفعل الضرر وترسل الرسائل بكل
الاتجاهات اذا ترسخت هذا الموضوع في
الصناعات هناك ما يسمى بالتراييل يعني
التجربه والخطا قد تحسن
المسيره الشاهد 136 بتكنولوجيا جديده
بتقدم جديد لتصبح اكثر تطورا وحتى تنافس
المسيرات الغربيه طيب عميد باختصار الان
الدول الغربيه تتواعد بانها لن تسمح بهذه
الشراكه ان تتطور باعتقادك ما الذي يمكن
ان تقوم به
بالحد الادنى هناك العقوبات بالحد الادنى
هناك تدخلات عسكريه سريه بمكان ما هناك
همم
الشراكه اصبحت امرا واقعا اصبحت عمليا
وماسسه ال سي بالحد الادنى همم الرد سياسي
بالحد الادنى الرد بالعقبات ونحن نعرف ان
العقوبات يعني اصبحت منذ العام 79 على
ايران وحتى الان لم تاتي بنتائجها التي
كانت تتوقع امريكا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على العميد الياس عنا
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
كنت ضيفنا من بيروت
ومشاهدين ان اذهب لمشاهده هذه الصور
الاخيره اذا صور من لندن وباريس
لمشجعين فريقي فرنسا وبريطانيا
في انتظار صافره الحكم لنهايه لنهايه هذا
لنهايه هذا
اللعبه بين هذه المواجهه بين فرنسا
وبريطانيا فرنسا تتصدر بهدفين بهدف
هي صور الاحتفالات في كل من
باريس ولندر
منتصف الليل المشاهدين بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
وهذا موجز باهم الانباء قبل الانتقال الى
يوميات المونديال
حضرت واشنط الساعه تنسيق العسكري بين
روسيا وايران في اوكرانيا وقالت مصادر
امريكيه ان هناك تفهم الايرانيه روسيا
لتزويد طهران بمقاتلات سخوري من جهته قال
جيمز كليفر لي وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
انما وصفه بالاتفاقات الدنيئه بين ايران
وروسيا تهدد الامن العالمي
من جهتها شددت موسكو على عدم تلقيها اين
امدادات عسكريه من ايران كما نفى مسؤول
ايراني رفيع الالتهابات الغربيه لبلاده
بتزويد روسيا بمئات المسيرات لاستخدامها
في اوكرانيا وقال للجزيره ان التلك
الاتهامات الاسس لها اضاف المسؤول
الايراني وانا اصرار واشنطن على ربط
المسيارات الايرانيه بحرب اوكرانيا هدفه
شيطاران وتصويرها طرفا في الحرب وقال
المسؤول الايراني للجزيره ان امريكا وحلفا
نيته يحاولان شيطانه علاقات بلادها
الدفاعيه مع روسيا لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
كشفت مصادر مطلعه لوكاله بلومبرج عن تفاقم
الخلاف بشان اسعار بشان سقف اسعار الغاز
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي قبيل الاجتماع
الطارئ لوزراء الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
الثلاثاء المقبل لمحاوله التواصل الى
اتفاق وبحسب تلك المصادر فان مجموعه من
اثنتي عشره دوله من بينها بلجيكا واليونان
وايطاليا وبولندا لوحات بعرقله اتفاق
لوضعه سقفا لسعر الغاز
دعج جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه المعارضه في تونس
لمقاطعه الانتخابات المقرره همم الاسبوع
المقبل ووصفتها بالمهزله كم انتقدت في
مظاهره ما وصفته بالعوده لحكم الفرد
المطلق في البلاد
من من نادي للقول فل نتكلم
وبريطانيا حيث انتهت بفوز فرنسا بهدفين
لهدف وبالتالي تاهل فرنسا
لمبارياتي نصف النهائي
في اطار مونديال قطر 2002 و 20 وهذا صور
من الاحتفالات في باريس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وبذلك نكون امام نصف نهائي تتواجه فيه
فرنسا مع المغرب نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]